iran schlägt zurück wie angekündigt
raketen treffen den irakischen
luftwaffenstützpunkt al assad kurz nach
mitternacht ziel us soldaten die auch
hier stationiert sind
ein von der rbs aufgenommenes video
zeigt den moment der einschlägen
iranische medien sprechen von 80
getöteten us terroristen
laut dem pentagon allerdings gebe es
bislang keine berichte über opfer auf
amerikanischer seite
in einem ersten tweet beruhigt präsident
trump alles ist gut derzeit würden
mögliche opfer und schäden bewertet
noch heute will der us-präsident sich
öffentlich äußern nicht nur der
stützpunkt al-assad im zentrum wurde
getroffen
auch erbil in der kurdenregion im
nordirak viele deutsche soldaten sind
hier zur ausbildung irakischer einheiten
stationiert
von unseren soldatinnen soldaten ist
niemand verletzt das heißt die erhöhten
schutz maßnahmen die wir auch schon
angeordnet haben haben gegriffen
wir haben mit der internationalen
koalition sowieso vereinbart dass alle
kräfte die nicht benötigt werden keine
unnötigen risiko ausgesetzt werden
der von den usa getötete general
soleimani wurde in kehrmann seine
geburtsstadt beigesetzt wenige stunden
vor den angriffen iran übt vergeltung
für seinen tod die angst vor einer
zuspitzung der lage im nahen osten
wächst
jörg brase in teheran wie sind die
iranischen angriffe zu bewerten
ja also man muss sehen dass es sich da
um ballistische raketen gehandelt hat
die aus großer entfernung abgefeuert
wurden und wir erwarten natürlich jetzt
noch auf die berichte über zerstörungen
und opfer aber die reaktion auch hier
auf iranischer seite waren doch wir
haben man muss sagen relativ verhalten
es gab einige äußerungen auf twitter von
regierungsmitgliedern außenminister
tarif hat sich geäußert und meinte es
habe sich dabei um einen legitimen akt
der selbstverteidigung gehandelt
das ziel der iranischen führung sei es
nach wie vor die usa aus der region zu
vertreiben ähnlich hat sich auch der
kommunikationsminister in einem tweet
geäußert
und vor wenigen minuten hat irans
staatsoberhaupt religionsführer
ayatollah khamenei hinkommen gesprochen
das war eine sehr verhalten eine sehr
bedachte rede
wo jetzt nicht mit schaum vor dem mund
gegen amerika gewettert wo der hammer
meinte man habe den amerikanern eine
ohrfeige gegeben und man werde also
jetzt auch das ziel weiter verfolgen die
amerikaner mit hilfe von verbündeten
regel staaten in der nachbarschaft aus
der region zu entfernen
und was ist bisher über den ablauf der
attacken bekannt also wir wissen bislang
nur dass es sich um ballistische raketen
handelt die offenbar von
raketenstellungen auf iranischem
staatsgebiet abgefeuert wurden über die
genaue zahl der opfer wissen wir im
moment noch nichts und es sieht aber im
moment auch nicht danach aus dass es
weitere vergeltungsschläge von
iranischer seite gibt insofern kann man
das glaube ich wirklich so bewerten das
war jetzt ein zeichen ein symbol dass
die iranische seite gesetzt hat und man
wartet jetzt auf die antwort der
amerikaner aber auch die scheint doch
eher auf deeskalation zu setzen als
darauf diesen schlag nun sofort zu
vergelten
vielen dank nach teheran den jörg brase
und gehen wir weiter nach brüssel zu
stefan leifert viele sehen ja derzeit
die europäer in der verantwortung
zwischen iran und den usa zu vermitteln
wie realistisch ist das also die
europäer hier in diesem konflikt als
vermittler zu sehen wäre glaube ich eine
überschätzung der rolle die die eu im
moment in diesem konflikt hat richtig
ist aber die europäer haben
oder gehört zu den wenigen die kontakte
in beide richtungen haben sowohl nach
washington als auch nach teheran
und diese kontakte zu nutzen das ist das
ziel aller eilig einberufenen treffen
die in brüssel jetzt stattfinden zur
stunde das sondertreffen der eu
kommission am freitag gibt es dann hier
ein sondertreffen der europäischen
außenminister die verfolgen damit zwei
ziele
das eine soll seien alle gesprächskanäle
zu nutzen um irgendwie deeskalierend auf
die lage einzuwirken und das zweite ziel
ist den iranern ein bekenntnis zum atom
deal abzuringen das prestigeobjekt der
europäer der letzten jahre
das abkommen ist zwar defekt
tot aber formal existiert es noch und
die europäer wollen auch den letzten
hauch von chance noch nutzen um den
iranern irgendwie ein bekenntnis zum
atom deal abzuringen man hat zu diesem
zweck auch den iranischen außenminister
nach brüssel eingeladen und es könnte
sogar sein
es gibt zumindest hier in brüssel die
hoffnung dass er am freitag zum
außenminister treffen kommt das zeigt
dass die europäer in einer ziemlich
schwierigen rolle zwischen allen stühlen
sind erstens und es zeigt zwei auch die
ganze machtlosigkeit der europäer in
dieser krise deswegen ist das ganze auch
eine erste bewährungsprobe für die neue
eu-kommission mit ursula von der leyen
an der spitze vielen dank stefan leifert